Sharon go plays it back to the Far Point but
nobody home was weaker and moved over and that
puck slides out for the calary Blue Line sharing
goich back on the attack by himself tries a shot
kicked Away by terasa puck picked up on the
far side by clapa and away he goes the big
Wier down the right side looks over the line
plays it across nice pass shot stop Adam clapa
looking for his first point at this level there's
a weird bounce right in front they score unlucky
break there marks from it gone behind the net
but the puck came free right back to chakov
and he's able to tuck it in and make a one-
nothing Columbus here's the attempt to shoot
the puck in right off the leg and of course if
you're the defenseman T of you have no idea you
think the puck is being dumped in behind the net
and of course it goes right back to the player C
it almost never happens and so when you see it
it's just like can't believe it Ms are pretty
good getting on the way usually here's Tanis
shot P sa back the rebound that's stopped as
well by terasa gets it up the boards and out as
he lifts it over the head of sharing goic weager
there HTO down the wing puts one through right
on goal terasoft Ste that away back to Anderson
slapshot and that's swallowed up by terasoft Adam
fan Tilly up from the four check plays it around
there's weager pass misses kept on side Bean
feeds it over good Branson shoots stopped by
marstrom tan here's carali with a steal gos
that on goal it's pluged by markstrom Coleman
in a battle along the far side with prover
off backland and Manon comes in Puck caught
up in feet now comes free man japani with a
back hand pass here's we over the shot score
mcki Winger with balls in
three straight games makes it
one1 and they're battling down low there's
Coleman backlands in there then M party comes
out with the puck watch Johnny control he's going
to try and sneak past the flames defens in case
there's a loose puck mapon gets it and fires it
back to weager with a beautiful backhand pass
that's the second nice backhand pass today's
game from mapani and he goes top shelf behind
terasa off the draw Jordan osterly feeds it
to Zer now corado with a shot turned away
by terasoft got a piece of that ran hus thought
porado was much better in game two than in game
one on the recall and boy is he a smooth skater
or what though G branon with a pass to carali shot
turned away off the end boards texier can't get
it up to the corner weager there feeds it ahead
and it's a good play by AJ Greer to chip it out
and then play it in Jake Bean back pla with a big
hit on bean pu goes to The Far Side caral feeds
it over to texier they work it in switch back
on the fence and it block save by markot Bean
could react giving up that strange goal early
here's the answer Pro off plays it out caral
able to feed it in deep marks from behind the
neet cuts it off and puts it off the board but
CED it up and they score a turnover by marstrom
right to sson and again with the Flames goalie
trying to scramble back to the crease the Blue
Jackets put it in play the puck so he threw
it along the far boards and it settles just
perfectly for Severson and he rips that far
side behind markstrom and if you're not not
sure you've got to put it high and hard on the
glass and that wasn't mission accomplished by
marrom and the Blue Jackets quickly go up settled
down by Shillington worked ahead to cadry and he
goes over the line with Zer pass to Zer back
to cadri loaded up as Anderson settles it down
cadri again Anderson one time or stop rebound
set free the score Zer tucks it in head two
watch cadri he knows he's got to get the puck
over the blue line so he does just that with a
little bit of help from Zer then a little give
and go cavri and rasas Anderson twice there's
that big bomb and right front there's Zer going
for the rebound Coronado is Around the Net as
well teraso can't find it and there's a little
hole just over the pad back the line coming on
good Branson plays it over coed up stolen Bon
jaon backlin here's Colin stopped by teras
and ter off down able to gather the puck back
in as we hit the final minute of Play In the
period Li l Jonathan huberto lyol one more
time tan side of the goal to shich in front
here's an with a shot sto by ter off and he's
able to fall on top of the rebound what a nice
play by Sharon gold throws it backand right
in front at hanifen which we've talked about
often real great feel for one to leave his point
position and attack in the offensive zone he gets
a fantastic chance and I think Columbus took
a penalty out all that by the way happy 27th
birthday to Noah Hanahan today tipped away here's
hubo shoots stopped rebound to the corner Jabs it
free but look up comes right to texier and now
it's a two-on-one with carali shot off the post
three by the score shorthanded ball Alex Tex
it's the first short antig goal of the year for
the Blue Jackets as he pots his own rebound and
makes it 3-2 and it starts with a great save by
terasa flank and he's in close and terasa great
chance good gron chips that putt free and watch
texier and carali on a two-on one Tex is going
to go far side right off the close man is that
the wherewithal right there to recognize the
puck is coming right back to him he settles
the puck down and chips a puck into the open
net so texier gets his seventh goal of the
Season ahead for hubero hubo CS in deep
at front get a shot away off a sck wi of
the goal then G gets control on his butt
what a backhand pass by h here's chikov
finds some room FL save markstrom jackets
up by one markstrom keeps it there 3-2 in
Calgary hubero pass down low weak shot by cry's
turned aside and the loose Puck Corral by singer
feeds it over chikov plays it back to the point
wensy Johnson shoots stop rebound him down Puck
still loose opportunities here's the first one
he's going to get the puck through the legs of
weager with tra those guys when they're rested
they're a whole lot more effective there's a
one timer they score tipped in by verono as
the shot ricocheted off Hanahan and Dimitri
verono on the power play makes it 4-2 Columbus
in the power play they weren't really setting
up for a one-time and this time they did fanelli
goes off hanifen right onto ronov and gives him
a 4-2 lead but I was kind of surprised they
didn't have a lot of one-time looks or setup
on this power back to Han with a shot stop
rebound scooped up chikov feeds to the head
and vantilly with the empty net and that will
I him with a minute 42 to go making it five3
glovis well terasa with a couple of big saves
and the Flames putting lots of pressure on the
goenda made a nice save there and then
a beautiful play by chikov getting it
to fanelli and he scores and he takes a peek
at the clock Oly does and just bumps it back
and that'll do it so the Flames battle back a
couple of times but three unanswered ultimately